Cuáles son los principales factores para
que se haya presentado este aumento en
las cifras de personas que sufren esta
disminución en la cifra de personas que
sufren hambre en el mundo yo creo
Rodrigo que están combinando cuatro
aspectos el primero naturalmente los
desequilibrios históricos en relación a
los esfuerzos para eliminar el hambre el
segundo sin duda en los aspectos
referidos a los efectos del covid como
tú señalabas en las cifras del tercero
son los aspectos relacionados al cambio
climático y el cuarto los aspectos
referidos a la guerra son cuatro
factores absolutamente explosivos y
realmente la señal de que el aumento no
haya sido lo mismo que el año pasado es
al menos una señal de que la situación
no va empeorando en forma dramática
entonces hemos visto una disminución
respecto al año pasado pero pese a todo
sigue aumentando la cifra y yo quería
preguntarle por uno de los factores de
los que me hablaba y quería preguntar
precisamente Cómo puede afectar el
cambio climático con sus fenómenos cada
vez más extremos en el desarrollo de los
índices de hambre
sin duda para los niveles de la
producción a niveles de precio creo que
nuestra América Latina del Caribe los
ejemplos de Centroamérica los factores
como el niño en el cual estamos
preparando y ayudando a preparar a los
productores Rurales para absorber parte
del impacto te muestran como se ha
transformado el tema del cambio
climático quizás en el factor más grave
más agresivo en relación a los
escenarios de inseguridad alimentaria
hablaba usted precisamente de la región
latinoamericana el informe señala una
cierta mejoría en las cifras dentro de
la región A qué se debe y qué retos se
enfrenta aún todavía América Latina para
seguir mejorando estos datos Yo diría
que es apenas una señal no podemos
hablar todavía de mejora si bien hay un
cero punto cinco menos en relación al
año anterior es una señal de que si esto
se mantiene quizás se transforme en
tendencia Pero tú sabes que para la
tendencia Necesitas ver el más de en más
de un año de cualquier manera yo creo
que más allá de la versión global que
nosotros podemos decir que hay algunas
luces positivas que empiezan a aparecer
si miramos en los escenarios
subregionales vemos una realidad de
Sudamérica un tanto coyunturalmente
mejorada vemos un escenario en
Centroamérica que no se ha modificado y
un escenario del Caribe que sigue
degradándose del punto de vista nacional
alimentaria particularmente empujado por
la situación dramática de Haití
justamente es informe tiene que
llevarnos a reflexionar de cómo
interactuar mejor en América Latina y el
Caribe Cómo apoyar mejor las zonas más
débiles para encontrar un escenario
mucho más equilibrado hacia el futuro
y respecto a esto que nos Comenta En qué
políticas o en qué proyectos trabaja la
FAO aquí dentro de la región para seguir
intentando mejorar esas cifras en primer
lugar nosotros damos muy fuerte respaldo
a la acción de los gobiernos que tiene
la responsabilidad central con el manejo
su presupuestos para definir un conjunto
de políticas que determinen esa
transformación las políticas son muchos
no es una sola pero uno de los aspectos
que nosotros más nos interesa es que
todos los grandes actores de la región
tienen que tener otro escenario de
energía estoy hablando del sector
privado de la sociedad civil de La
Academia y estoy hablando de que tiene
que haber una nueva fase de la
integración regional o sea una
participación mucho más integrada entre
los diferentes países de América Latina
y el Caribe para lograr nuevas formas de
confluencia la integración a veces la
hablamos solamente del punto de vista
comercial o fronterizo y yo creo que la
integración para la seguridad
alimentaria es uno de los temas
absolutamente claves si efectivamente
queremos que la región vaya en la
dirección de una estabilidad de nuevo
tipo y un mejor escenario de seguridad
alimentaria que De cualquier manera
sigue siendo muy alto porque nos
referimos a que todavía 43 millones de
personas está en un escenario de hambre